bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono pochi generi trattati
con sempre fare su un gioco che avete
amato da morire perché penso che sia
impossibile non amarlo che è avvocato lo
siamo ritornati poi ci sfidiamo io
perché step st gago tutto in mano non è
giusto non lo fa non vale se è stato mio
personaggio si sta muovendo aiuto non si
può anche perché si è sbloccato
l'obiettivo ragazzi per chi non
conoscesse avvocato ma non ci credo che
trovato l'arma viola subito
mamma mia che male si va a spiegare il
gioco quindi l'obiettivo è quello di
buttare gli altri fuori dalla mappa
penso che sta infici stia per riuscire a
meno che non esca prima lui da solo sia
incinta e io c'è il ghiaccio tore che
potrebbe essere utile se solo pc
qualcuno non è vero non è vero non è
vero che la guarda che guarda che lui
pensa alle cose e ci riesce pure e ci
riesce capito se non solo le pensa ci
riesce a mia madre io allora ecco questa
questa roba qui vedete qui ma che in
questo si può prima ma e leo aperti
tutti i tool anche io non funziona
niente fidati di me non ammazzate
nessuno a priori dell'arma che trovate
prendete due rovini ali dobbiamo mettere
del pil è un dato così sicuro di sé del
kraken aveva mai fatto
no per ora è quello che ho letto nei
commenti come come rivista la mappa o
collegate mi sembra veramente 19 non c'è
io ho messo da solo
io sono mai solenne aprile forzieri non
gravare i tesori ma ecco tutta la
giornata mappe ti sparo perché allora
aspetti che sto arrivando
se aspettiamo aspettiamo messo vedete
cosa sta succedendo ragazzo bellissimo
ci sta io raga è che bruxelles
cos'è numero avanti ma non farà da non
sto facendo niente stai a un bottone
piace a votarne schiacciandole delle
armi anti di armi
d'acqua e poi non lo so non ho idea
questo abbiamo colpire tipo il versato a
questa squadra delle armi o meglio una
ventola di entrate quello cercando di
spagna cos'è cos'è non lo so brava
allora credo che non debba guardavano ti
prego l'ho fatto ha funzionato ragazzi
le paro con un lucchetto e vero c'è un
lucchetto dobbiamo aprire un lucchetto e
la chiave non lo so vorrei che c'è
attenzione kraken di la botta la vedete
che avete la botola con un segno secondo
me magari sparando questa succede
qualcosa ma non ci vuole la roma
magari si apre con l'acqua quando
secondo momento l'acqua mai trovata
chiave della barca usa la luiss e la
chiave no mamma mia che cosa rischiava
prendi la chiave ce l'ho fatta occhio la
via è brava spingi la spina e malocchio
chiocchio chiocchio occhio attaccati
attaccati ce la siamo giocata
incredibile che svela vi siete prendere
io sono mezzo fuori ma ancora no aiuto e
comporta male non si creda pugno su
persone pagano al pugno su persone con
un bellissimo comunque al mio dio no
volevo questo anno esatto
mamma mia ragazzi che può già avere
detto no
però devi smetta di spararmi addosso
spara spara step
ma cosa ma le ragazze di gli utenti di
parti umane ma mollami ma chi vuoi
sparare ai a non funziona e pacco su
madonna che male aiuto aspetti a risale
il posto di menti mio di ofere scusa ma
renzi più a sette secondi per buttarmi
giù e penso che ce la farà ma no spettro
ai due armi oggi si cambia perché non lo
prende niente ma dai mi vuoi finire
malissimo decidere marrazzo lo tiriamo
ti stai ma dall'altro vai e poi via
carattere non sono veritieri mi ritengo
che sulla grappa capire dove sta andando
dov'è che va aiuto e latino come el al
ha vinto step diciamola devo il mio
mandato maledizione modifica carità
modifica la gravità e sempre bello
perché poi poli a caso frequentiamo
tutti da con demonio parco no che botta
sono a posto siamo incastrati non
possono scendere nel salire rimango qua
no prosegue oggi fa fuori la gente non
sa che i ragazzi
ma cos'è uno spara grazie a majano che
poteva trovare lo tengo io il granchio
lo tengo io volevo salvare il granchio
non sono uscito ti prego fa che muoia
step potrei vivere
pensa se fai perdi tu sito in gravissimo
affanno skyphos di granchi c'è una bomba
viola non l'ho mai vista nè stessa roba
cos'è questa regata in cui nomi sono
stato mi sono distratto il grande occhio
ci credo è che non vedo fiera di granchi
per nella prima ma l'altro step due ore
dopo a ragazzi questi problemi di coppia
perché io e lì da due anni non ti metti
a vincere
prima le donne no no no e sono morto io
infatti pensate vanta mi ha rotto le
scatole
ha vinto perché per l'impazienza
incredibile anzi tv tv sotto succede
l'incredibile
va beh sì qua sento ragazzi l'ho fatto
già molto ma facci vedere facce note
maledizione non siete cascati ha deciso
di altri però non c'entra più perché
grossa maledizione non ci sei cascato
vorrei che siccome poi spara ancora
esatto poi sono uscite cose v 90 ma che
male ci siamo dati una poesia diventa
anche gigante ma basta questi colossi
per incanto orami seguire a io a
domandare per non far eseguire per
uccidermi per ricalibrare anche se
successo si è incartato sono diventata
gigante quando stavo qui stop mi sono
immediatamente incastrata aiuto poi far
niente perché non ci enti qui il mio
addio
cosa ho visto come fai essere vivo come
fai essere vivo come fossi ragazzi che
lo sto vedendo la ragazza sale mentre
idea ma io mi son visto salvando c'è
solo tu puoi morire lì fuori
106 camper è tanto non posso uscire più
che altro tempio 600 grandi no anche tu
vuoi mettere v.lo freddo non l'ho preso
e va tutto non puoi uccidermi
ora quanti granchi esistono anguille ma
che ho vinto io non ci credo anguilla
telo bravo ma colui che sta in casa ma
dai ma perché perché non perché
continuavano
ci credo voglio dire voglio mai bike e
sconfitta in meritatissima io non ho mai
capito come si sa della sua bravura ma
neanche io non lo farei ma tommy sono
salvato per un niente
al sesto gioco libero lo capitolo capito
sono la parte non sono riusciti a fare
io ho la mia idea ha fallito quindi a
quel punto mi ammazzo vulcano
non male debutto i teschi tipo nella
lava facciamo una sorta di rituale è
quello che conta però prova aspetta
voglio provarci davvero paghiamo quello
è un piccione ho buttato
devo anche il piccione ah ecco fatto
confusione dentro non è successo niente
non è successo
no non ci credo l'ama si è aggrappato
dai maya che dolore al collo
vai
e porti la parola mio dio creazioni che
si paga la visuale non vedo niente step
vai giù mai
non vedo nulla dai che siamo al limite
ma puoi aprire per e dolore dolori simo
ciao con la propulsione dai ragazzi mi
aspetto che arrivi una star ma qui c'è
tanti magari non ci credo che dolore
male l'ultima mai
ok dai dobbiamo assolutamente fare
questo quindi ragazzi un credo che
l'episodio di avocado non siamo per
votare il cracking come vedrete nel
prossimo episodio speriamo di esserci
riusciti
mettete mi piace lasciate un bel like
che la stessa cosa però ha detto devo
dire che ti è accaduto nella passata
canister e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo però ragazzi
[Musica]